[Música]
a gente olha para essas imagens de
dessas três cidades são paulo rio de
janeiro manaus a gente vê é são paulo
com seus diferentes prédios seus muitos
prédios rio de janeiro com seus muitos
pontos turísticos suas muitas praias a
gente vê manaus com o lindo rio negro
passando ali por trás
brasília onde se toma as principais
decisões do país
cuiabá que está do lado da linha do
pantanal curitiba com as suas diversas
áreas verdes e o que a gente observa é
que a gente então tem uma infinidade de
diferenças de pluralidade nas cidades
brasileiras
isso impacta diretamente em aspectos
culturais das cidades
então quando a gente pensa em são paulo
a gente pensa nos seus diferentes museus
a gente pensa nos shopping centers nas
compras e etc
mas quando a gente por exemplo pensa no
rio de janeiro a gente pensa nos pontos
turísticos nas praias nos blocos de rua
no carnaval e cidades inteligentes como
que fica nisso tudo quando a gente fala
de cidades inteligentes gente sempre
pensa muito em tecnologia
a gente pensa nas câmeras a gente pensa
em sistemas de vigilância a gente pensa
em sistemas de mobilidade urbana como
por exemplo brt
a gente pensa em centro de operações
como tem na prefeitura do rio de janeiro
mas cidades inteligentes envolve muito
mais do que isso cidades inteligentes
envolvem sustentabilidade e portanto
várias questões relacionadas ao meio
ambiente mas não só o meio ambiente a
gente pensa também na questão é a das
economias e e o quanto que a gente pensa
em soluções sustentáveis do ponto de
vista econômico
a gente tem que pensar em qualidade de
vida e portanto nos parques nos espaços
para esporte para a prática de
atividades físicas pra programas
culturais mas principalmente a gente tem
que pensar na inovação social
a gente tem que pensar em como que a
gente desenvolve soluções para cidades
que atinjam todas as parcelas da
população e não somente uma delas ou uma
parte delas e portanto pra gente
identificar que as iniciativas cidades
inteligentes são de sucesso
a gente tem que identificar qual é o
valor público dessas iniciativas
e quanto maior o quanto mais alto for o
valor público agregado mas a mais
importante
vão ser essas soluções mas pra que o que
quer valor público valor público é algo
difícil de mensurar porque se você
comparar uma pessoa que sente a
necessidade da educação da saúde pública
e outro que é um empresário que precisa
desenvolver a economia e tem vários
funcionários ali da sua empresa que ele
tem que pagar então muitas vezes é muito
antagônico né os objetivos são muito
distintos épocas diferentes para
diferentes pessoas
mas e como que então eu faço pra que as
pessoas entendam que aquelas soluções
são importantes para elas
elas precisam fazer parte do processo
democrático de cidade e pra fazer parte
elas têm que ter primeiro passo acesso à
informação e para ter acesso à
informação a gente tem a lei de acesso à
informação federal que obriga que todos
os órgãos públicos disponibilizem seus
dados
e aí começa a tentar um movimento de
dados abertos por exemplo a cidade do
rio de janeiro ela tem o portal data
ponto rio onde entre coleções de dados
abertos que são categorizados que são
agrupadas em diferentes grupos a e como
esses dados são disponibilizados
eu peguei aqui uma coleção de dados por
exemplo de academias da terceira idade
no rio de janeiro e aí eu tenho diversas
colunas de dados
e aí uma das perguntas que poderia fazer
pra nessa coleção me responder quantas
academias eu tenho por bairro ou com a
distribuição geográfica dessas academias
pela cidade do rio de janeiro
e aí isso eu tô dando somente dois
exemplos de várias outras possibilidades
de centenas de coleções de dados que têm
disponíveis nesses portais e pra que eu
comece a trabalhar isso com cidade
a gente como é tem que começar isso na
educação básica que a gente precisa
começar a trabalhar com esses estudantes
de tal maneira que eles se sintam e
consigam participar e ter uma
consciência muito maior dos processos
que ele vive na cidade há e então pra eu
fazer à empresa eu fazer então análise
de dados
eu tenho que ter conhecimentos de
matemática de geografia eu tenho que ter
conhecimentos de português português
condado em que saber contar como que
aquele dado chega uma determinada
informação determinado momento novo
a opor o processo de análise de dados
portanto ele começa no acesso
ele começa quando esse cidadão descobre
que existem dados o que ele pode
solicitar dados a lei de acesso à
informação e à lei da transparência
obriga que os órgãos disponibiliza e
dados para a população
então eu começo o acesso depois do
comércio pelo reconhecimento do dado eu
preciso reconhecer e identificar e
entender o que está sendo
disponibilizado e depois vai a análise
propriamente dita que o processo de
olhar para esse dado adquirido formação
adquirir conhecimento e eu volto nesse
círculo virtuoso proacesso porque
eventualmente eu posso descobrir eu
preciso de novos dados e assim
sucessivamente
além da matemática geografia e cetro uma
das coisas que a gente que é importante
também neste processo eo pensamento
computacional o pensamento computacional
ele visa a solução de problemas
é eu acho que um dos problemas que a
gente vive na educação é que muitas
vezes há o conhecimento é passado sem
que se trabalhe por meio de problema
para se encontrar soluções e o
pensamento computacional ele vem um
pouco para tentar treinar as pessoas a
resolver problemas
então a partir do problema eu penso em
geração de idéias mas existem quatro
itens fundamentais eu partir do problema
é chegar na solução
o primeiro é a decomposição que é o de
compor o problema que eu tenho que
resolver em diferentes partes
então por exemplo carregar é um objecto
de 160 quilos
pode ser muito difícil pra mim se eu não
tiver algum instrumento que ajude mas eu
posso quebrar eventualmente em oito
pedaços de 20 quilos está então e esse é
um exemplo bem simples existem outras
outras
outros exemplos de decomposição muito
mais complexos
o reconhecimento de padrões é envolvem
eu treinar esse estudante ou levar esse
estudante a identificar padrões além
daquilo que ele já está acostumado
então por exemplo a ele identificar
além da árvore que realize os animais e
isso requer um pouco de de treino com
esses estudantes não enxergar somente
animais em enxergar também os seres
humanos ou olhar uma série de dados
vem cá padrões de oscilação desses dados
por exemplo identificação de freqüência
de como está é e por aí vai
o conceito de abstração é o item
abstração é a gente que desde criancinha
a gente é treinado pra os mais
diferentes cachorros a gente consegue
identificar que existe um conceito por
trás chamado cachorro a cadeira mesmo
que a cadeira tem a 4 quatro rodinhas ou
quatro pés ou três pés ou um custo não
tem um custo tem o apoio de braço não a
gente tem um conceito chamado cadeira
que está no nosso consciente e aí
trabalhar então com outras maneiras de
abstração nos mais diferentes níveis
também é um conceito importante do
pensamento computacional e por último é
e eu acho que esse é o mais importante é
a construção de apetite - quando você
fala ano não fazer um bolo que você dá o
passo a passo para fazer um bolo quando
você pensa no passo a passo para trocar
uma lâmpada ou lâmpadas mais complexas
como uma lâmpada de um carro é esse
processo é de quebrar o problema então
em diversas partes identificar os
conceitos já é mais genéricos que têm
por trás daquilo que está trabalhando e
pensar no passo a passo
são todos os itens importantes de se
começar a trabalhar já desde a educação
básica
a robótica educacional
e à programação por blocos é uma maneira
de se fazer isso né existem outras
ferramentas como scratch diversas outras
que se pode trabalhar aqui é 11 uma
experiência que a gente tem na uff
juntando os alunos do ensino superior
com os estudantes da educação básica e
por fim uma das coisas que é muito
importante quando a gente começa a
pensar em dados abertos seria os
hackathons a gente sempre pensa no verbo
hackear como algo ruim mas o hackear ele
vende eu dar um novo olhar para algo que
que já existe né
para tentar criar novas soluções e os
hackathons para a cidade
o haxixe é um movimento da rede
brasileira de cidades inteligentes e
humanas vários já foram desenvolvidos já
foram realizados em cidades brasileiras
surgindo novas soluções para cidades
trazendo os novos olhares e aí uma das
perguntas que a gente traz pra cá atrás
pra vocês pra gente questionar pra gente
pensar então como que eu posso pensar em
raqa educação por meio de dados abertos
por meio de pensamento computacional
como que o transforma esses cidadãos em
cidadãos muito mais conscientes
como que eu trago um termo que cada vez
hoje se ouve mais que a literacia
digital ou literacia digital para fazer
com que os nossos estudantes sejam
cidadãos mais conscientes mais
participativos
eu vejo muitas vezes comentários no
facebook do tipo eu copiei algo que
alguém falou mas as pessoas têm
dificuldade de fazer a argumentação e aí
quando você usa os dados para adquirir
mais informação para adquirir mais
conhecimento você trabalha também a
argumentação e as suas decisões baseadas
em dados em acesso à informação relação
muito mais é fortes do que é você tomar
decisões é de maneira que na verdade
alguém disse você copia então isso a
gente eu acredito que a gente tem que
começar a trabalhar desde a educação
básica em todo movimento e aí eu tenho
trabalhado muito com essa sequência
aspecto de dados abertos
como que a gente constrói ferramentas
também para facilitar esse processo de
interpretação mas isso eu acho que a
gente tem um longo trabalho pela frente
e aí então fica a pergunta tinha final
pra vocês como que a gente hackeia
educação e transforma nossos nossos
estudantes em cidadãos mais conscientes
e se obrigada gente
[Aplausos]
[Música]